hallo heute drehen wir eine neue folge
super easy german wir sind in einer
schule in tschechien niveau sind wir
investiert wie heißt die schule sehr mg
und wie heißt eure lehrerin werden
marica war formelles cora hat uns
hierhin eingeladen heute ist unser thema
das perfekt da kommt schon die politik
heute erklären wir wie man im deutschen
das perfekt bildet frau deutschlehrerin
wie macht man das perfekt also wer
konjugieren hilfswerk haben oder sein
und dazu bilden wir partizip 2 und party
zwei muss am ende des satzes stehen
das sind schon die wichtigsten regeln
zum beispiel laufen ist gelaufen
ich laufe ich bin gelaufen oder trinken
hat getrunken
ich trinke ich habe getrunken
jetzt gucken wir uns das in der klasse
an victoria schlecht im unterricht im
unterricht victoria hat im unterricht
geschlafen
ich denke was klarer hat wasser
getrunken
carolina was machst du ich mag ein bild
fertig carolina hat ein bild gemalt
philipp was machst du so lasar deutsche
was hast du gemacht ich habe nichts
gelernt
philipp hat deutsch im buch gelernt aber
er hat dabei nichts gelernt
ich ziehe die strickjacke an theresa hat
die strickjacke angezogen
eliska läuft in der klasse herum
eliska ist in der klasse herumgelaufen
die lehrerin kommt in die klasse die
lehrerin ist in die kasse gekommen
plötzlich sind alle aufgestanden und es
ist ruhig julia ganze wird er das
fenster aufmachen
julia steht aus und macht das fenster
auf julia ist aufgestanden und hat das
fenster aufgemacht
ich will hier die daten
anita hat die tafel gewischt
ich lege das handy auf den tisch
carolina hat das handy auf den tisch
gelegt eliska geht nach hause
eliska ist nach hause gegangen
die gruppe wird die waffeln crepes
challenge sie hat die flasche geworfen
die flasche ist stehend auf den tisch
gelandet
das war super easy firmen aus dem bmg
gymnasium in france
danke für eure einladung
[Musik]